ruhig schon mal vorgemacht und applaus
schritt auf esther hochgeladen
heute allerdings sich um ein paar mails
word orte des fortschritts trainingsplan
gehen sondern um rich kids auf die
talkmasterin switches
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was sie haben den eigenen kreisverkehr
in ihrer einfahrt die haben einen enorm
riesigen pool
sie haben eine versteckte tür dahinter
einen versteckten raum eine stange einen
eigenen baseball dings und ein eigenes
gym
handball westwien switches in der fas
gemalt hat
indoor im aus und das kino dazu seien
komplett nebensächlich donnerstag
ja komm wedel film alle deine gucci
gürtel und louis vuitton taschen und was
weiß ich
gute zeit mehr präsentation mal best
friend we check
[Musik]
[Applaus]
best brands hatch
[Musik]
das badezimmer hat mir den rest gegeben
1 eigene kletterwand geil auch dass ich
als erstes die kletterwand bewunderung
nicht irgendwie die lagerhalle voll mit
autos oder die eigene rutsche oder nein
ja ich dieser trend ist so komisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass so was halt echt peanuts gegen so
leute die da ihre fetten will mitziehen
weil sie nicht mehr ihre eigenen festen
willen das sind einfach das einfach nur
das geld von den eltern
[Musik]
darauf bin ich wirklich extrem leiden
natürlich safe auch später in meinem
haus haben und zwar einfach so
entertainment keller bis zum
billardtisch mit seinem fernseher mit
seiner eigenen kleinen bar wo man damit
seinen homies schönen können
[Musik]
pulis schon geil aber ich finde so ein
eigenes gym zu hause noch mal viel
geiler my best friend we check
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich mein schönes haus aber hin oder
her die haustür bestand aus glas das
heißt wenn ich ein bisschen creepy yao
dicker kommen liste alle deine uhren auf
deinen aber auf hier meine uhr
wie findet ihr die aber dass der typ am
ende dann auch seinen und youtube dollar
ich denn jetzt hieße expensive das ist
ich habe das sagt schon alles bestens
erst jetzt nur die karren gefilmt die
haben doch gar kein haus so die wohl
einfach in den autos
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum willst du deinen latschen heimat
best friend sorry der hat thorsten
ritsch
[Musik]
ich meine alle videos erwarte mir sehen
komisch aber die meisten haben es seien
einfach so gezeigt hätten dass das haus
von meinem besten freund oder von halb
von den eltern meines besten freundes
aber die wie eine braut oder menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend my best
friend we check
einfach im lamborghini bentley und range
rover in der garage von dem haus mal
ganz abgesehen dass die das ist auch
noch wie sichern hat einen pool und hat
auch einen jim und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
glückwunsch mal bestens richie
[Musik]
vom bentley posen aber 14 jahre alt sein
da die nicht mehr fahren dürfen
was ist das für eine bude liga mit
meinen fahrstuhl drin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ok hat sie am ende des videos ernsthaft
damit angegeben dass sie sich ein teures
abo bestellen konnte ja mein bestes
match
[Musik]
ihr seid die sache dass das haus
komplett auf land ist das teuerste
wohnhaus baust und eine wohnung kauft
whatever ist einfach die lage
und wenn du die natürlichen hausbaus
mittel
im niemandsland dann kostet das
natürlich auch nicht so viel und dann
kann man es natürlich auch schön
gestalten also das muss man natürlich
auch mal in betracht ziehen
[Musik]
einfach nur den ferrari film
wahrscheinlich sind wieder solo die
haben so eine garage aber essen und
trinken und schlafen hat dann alle fünf
ferrari
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja wahrscheinlich schützt du im bett mit
schuhen völlig völlig natural das war
krass
sondern alter lamborghini in der ferrari
lamborghini
die tu ich bin lena gomez ich habe hier
of us who die und kapuze auf niemand
darf mich sehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum
[Musik]
warum hat er in seinem schuhregal eine
mappe drin stehen wo eine menge bargeld
drin ist ist der drogendealer oder was
das ist locker einfach irgendwie so ein
schloss was die besichtigt haben im
umkreis im wald oder so ich meine schaut
euch das ja an so die kommen nicht mal
selbst rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der einen seite finde ich cool so mir so
coole autos anzuschauen und coole häuser
und so die der film auf der anderen
seite ist es so fremdschämen und
irgendwie
[Musik]
biosprit
er schaut mich an ich habe nicht eine
anständige frisur mal bestens mit check
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der film ist einfach nur den audi und
ist ein stinknormaler audi das ist das
ist das ist das sind life balls grad
gewesen mybestbrands witczak
[Musik]
warum
es ist einfach ein portemonnaie und ein
armband mal bestens
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube man merkt wie ich mit
zunehmender dauer des videos zunehmend
aggressiver und deprimierter werde
[Musik]
bestens mit check
mein bestes match
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du stehst einfach in einem klamotten
geschäft
[Musik]
wie sieht ja auch noch in posen ist so
von wegen hacker bin so reich ist dein
vater der reich ist oder deine mutter
war nicht mein bestes match check
warum willst du dein car wash zettelchen
autowäsche kosten 10 am besten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das haus ist noch nicht mal fertig
gebaut
das ist größer als ein krankenhaus my
best friend we check
ich finde diese braunen louis vuitton
taschen die sehen einfach nach 80er
jahre oma aus vor wir nun allerdings zum
letzten best friend rich hit tik tok
video what ever und zwar seine person
die das ganze anders herum gemacht hat
aber seht einfach selbst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so wird das dann auch bei mir aussehen
anderer stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings ob meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter video das
schreiben in die kommentare bock auf
einen zweiten teil hätte uns hier ist
jetzt ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf könnte man kann mal kostenlos
abonnieren wenn ihr noch kein luxus sein
dann verpasst er keine videos mehr wenn
ihr darauf den clásico held macht das
hier ist ein anderes video verlinkt
könnt ihr auch draufklicken da geht es
auch um bereiche person und zwar keine
jenner
das ist die jüngste milliardär in der
welt
klingt das anders